11h du matin dont les cuisines du
chebeya près d'orléans
chacun est à son poste
tout doit être prêt pour le service de
midi et demi au menu aujourd'hui du
potiron rôti au miel avec une tout autre
ait un qui a dû confondre da tomates
fraîches
ainsi que des des piments sans oublier
quelques feuilles de menthe ciselée pour
parfaire la présentation
[Musique]
avant d'envoyer en salle
qui ont repris au miel faux frais temps
normal pas tout à fait ce restaurant est
celui d'un ehpad est ici le chef cuisine
chaque jour 180 repas complet c'est bon
moi ça me ferait on a bientôt
si ses pensionnaires se régale c'est
parce qu'ici on a des lycées
l'industriel au profit des produits
frais et le coup on a notre fournisseur
qui est qui et surtout re voilà les
produits sont 150 kilomètres à la ronde
de tours juste hâtivement parlant ça
rien à voir quoi travailler des produits
frais c'est pas le même goût c'est enfin
voilà quoi c
c'est une évidence
des efforts remarqués par le célèbre
guide gastronomique gault et millau
il récompense régulièrement les
restaurants du groupe qui se démarquent
bel appétit en danger tout ça
vous mangez cas vous pouvez mais vous
verrez c'est très bon
en tout 68 ehpad ont reçu le prestigieux
label preuve qu'il est possible d'offrir
une cuisine de grande qualité en très
grande quantité
un modèle qu'une loi votée en 2018
généralise dans tous les restaurants
collectifs publics et certains
restaurants privés cette voie a été
imaginée lors des états généraux de
l'alimentation d'où son nom et galim
dans le public elle impose aux assiettes
servies dans les écoles collèges lycées
ou tout autre établissement comme les
hôpitaux un minimum de 50 % de produits
de qualité à l'année
20% de cette assiette doit être dédiée
aux produits bio le reste que se
répartir sur d'autres labels de qualité
comme les sigles aop au gp des quotas à
respecter
depuis le 1er janvier 2020
sacha ménard est responsable de la
production de la cuisine centrale de
tours bonjour
ça va merci
sa cuisine a plutôt misé sur les
circuits de proximité pour remplir les
objectifs de la loi c'est à moins d'une
heure de route à bex le château qu'ils
s'approvisionnent en lentilles bio oui
on est sur du 5 5
environ la cuisine centrale de tours
après ce qu attend les 20% de bio et
continue à chercher des partenaires
locaux pour remplir l'objectif voit les
huiles de tournesol et les huiles de
colza ça peut permettre d'augmenter
notre part de local de bio et de faire
deux produits made in touraine
cependant pour espérer retrouver ses
huiles dans sa cuisine il faudra passer
par un appel d'offres obligatoire pour
tout marché public
les lentilles de la maison joubert elles
ont le feu vert et font route vers ton
[Musique]